ça moi je suis allé faire les courses et
ouais ça m'arrivait vous savez des fois
sur le paquet serial ya des petites
annonces du genre trouve top au québec
son petit bidon paquet le calme études
enfin je rigole évidemment un pokédex en
plastique entre est celui que j'ai
retrouvé tout pokédex au plastique merci
mans mais là cette fois
j'ai craqué je l'achetais direct est ce
qu'ils se foutent de notre gueule mais
je me suis imaginé que si jamais des
recettes apparence tout à fait médiocre
clarifier et cette qualité pitoyable
est ce que il pourrait se cacher un vrai
sabre laser un vrai truc comme dans star
wars beaulieu imaginez qu'un mec l'actif
sans faire exprès lorsqu'il en train de
manger régulièrement salaires
mais le pire dans social rc7 annonces
mensongères sur l'eau du bac et obtient
les quatre cuillères devient super jedi
non non non désolé non mais troisième le
gars qui a acheté quatre paquets
différents et qui tombait sur les quatre
cuillères différentes
la technique où elle écoule la dernière
clearsea c'est vrai que vous êtes une
publicité la société puisqu'elle est
porteur moi j'ai les quatre parce que je
suis je suis ton père c'est alors tu
voisines situées n'acheter qu'un paquet
que tu n'as qu'une cuillère et tu tombes
sur un gars qui a acheté les quatre et
qui est donc devenu un jedi
non mais sérieusement c'est la lecture
faite attention les gars ils possèdent
les quatre cuillères le voile à la barre
couret enfin bref en gros je me suis
même pas dans la musique du temps
j'imagine des trucs en regardant la
couverture après quelques cow boys ça
c'est pas la mort
[Musique]
le monde sait ce quiz et il est
aujourd'hui on ne se retrouve pas sur un
jeu en 3d super méga de la mort qui tue
mais sur un jeu flash donc ça devrait
seulement vous rappeler votre enfance
quand vous aviez tout 7 8 9 ans ou
peut-être qu actuellement vous avez 7 8
9 ans enfin bref à mon époque on jouait
à des jeux flash notamment sur un jeu
qui s'appelait absolue de flash je suis
trop quoi et on se retrouve aujourd'hui
sur eyed peas donc en fait c'est un jeu
flash que j'ai découvert par hasard sur
youtube donc en fait c'est un jeu très
réputé chez les youtuber américains ou
anglais et vous allez voir que ses
pépins de mégaphones
alors écoutez on va plaire alors là vous
voyez on choisit son level donc des
level ou merde excusez moi faut pas que
je touche 1 savoie la dlv donc fait part
des joueurs merde voilà donc des
nouvelles fait part des joueurs donc
écouté j'ai regardé un petit peu juste
avant voyez donc ils sont notés par les
étoiles combien de fois ils ont été
joués sur était juste si milan fait doit
être génial à renwez jouer donc pour
satané vous ont choisi son aaa vous
allez voir le but du jeu c'est
totalement n'importe quoi vous allez
très vite comprendre bon à ce jeu les
gens c'est quoi as un petit bout de tête
c'est ce qui reste de mon personnage là
le petit rat deal avec vous voyez à à ce
jeu c'est n'importe quoi les gens est en
fait le but c'est de finir le niveau et
c'est en fait un jeu mais via gore en
jeu flash z'allez voir et ses côtés lui
toi en ont un et mer mais bloque le trou
du cul annonce est bon mais des voix qui
s'est totalement débile et totalement go
envoyer les bleus à c'est n'importe quoi
c'est n'importe quoi va essayer de le
finir vous voyez c'est ça et chaque
niveau on se bidonne du récit c'est que
des conneries les personnes sont
ridicules y en a un et leur vélo avec un
enfant à l'arrière lui ça c'est un gros
black sur une tondeuse et y en a un
outil c'est indiana jones mais je vais
le jouer juste et vous allez voir c'est
juste épique et à merde et un voyage
vraiment de rigoler comme j'avais alors
attendez on va changer de merde aux
suisses suis-je bête non je sais que tu
as dit que j'étais devant ton écran mais
je ne me suis pas fait on va changer on
va prendre suis là vous allez voir vous
allez bien rire c'est un level avec
indiana jones et vous allez super league
alors voilà on est diane à jaws donc on
est dans du pain cette petite en espèces
de jungle sur des rails
vous allez voir car manger à le but
c'est de rester droit et ses traits du
roi aléas des panneaux ce club où
j'aurai dû peut-être dû ralentir au
hockey non non non non non non bon bah
voilà
mais franchement les gens si vous voulez
découvrir et c'est un peu est repassé à
des jeux à l'ancienne de franchement je
vous conseille vraiment et puis oui il
se mettrait à lire dans la description
pour ceux qui veulent y jouer
ah merde [ __ ] et ce qui est rigolo ce
qui est rigolo c'est que quand le truc
se retourne on ne meurt pas forcément
regarder par exemple regardez je me
retourne et vous allez voir que auboyer
jeu on meurt pas forcément alors que
dans plein de jeux à barchon moment le
truc se retourne ce moment c'est fini
pour nous mais là non là c'est pas le
cas c'est vraiment qu'on se prend un pic
ou point mur de pleine face super vite
ou quoi qu'on meurt et franchement c'est
super non non le rhum blanc voilà dans
l'hexagone on va essayer de tester des
niveaux que je n'ai jamais fait
pokémon twining ça a l'air sympa ça ou
au choix ou regarder a choisi le
bonhomme donc un vieux en fauteuil
roulant oh merde j'ai pris un gain ok
bon ben ok cela n'est guen
waouh ça lui mais il faut faire quoi bah
c'est quoi d un nom il a plus de gens il
est affligeant
mon dieu regardez ses jambes ça on en on
on and on a balayé la plus rien là à bah
ouais ah bah oui mais chez moi
mais où sont mes jambes mais je ne
retrouve plus les banques ahli où il se
fait mal aux mais ces épi
mais regardez mais comme c'est épique
bon attendez voyez une pokéball tito au
début du niveau on leur attention
hop la faune on recule recule recule
voilà déjà j'ai eu chaud
alors attendez on passait de hockey bon
là il perd ces gens je pense que c'est
obligatoire
l'espace quoi waouh donc dieu
ok maintenant assez kouadja ce pokémon h
et plus du tout et me dit bien quelque
chose
ah mais ça doit être un récent ce pour
ça je connais pas les rails
ouais ok ok tu peux a reculé jeudi glee
pouf is coming
ah oui je les suivais 2 à l'aller a pu
toutes jambes
hop on roule sur un gros lard au
mouloudia
c'est quoi ce jeu mais ça arrive mais
c'est voyez ce genre de délire et je me
suis aussi pour l'intro encore une fois
ça me vient de mes petits délires
j'avais envie de me marier un coup je me
suis dit mais vous imaginez que ça
serait les vrais symboles majeurs qu'il
faudrait dans les trucs ça pourrait être
dangereux
enfin bref non waouh j'ai eu très chaud
j'ai eu très très chaud on va continuer
lyall à la tête de roudoudou qui va
venir fois que je fasse vite on va
ralentir un peu et on n'a pas du tout
ralenti vite recule recule recule à 1
à vue vita mais je vous jure mais quand
vous voulez décompresser d'une journée
de merde vous pouvez vous jouer à ce jeu
au maire j'ai encore baisser franchement
c'est c'est juste du pur bonheur au
moins vous ne rêvez pas allez on va
prendre celui là il est marrant ce
verseaula en fauteuil roulant il est
plutôt marrant waouh je suis ou au c'est
quoi le délire y avait une voiture et
qu'elles gagnent à temps mais comment il
est devenu jack o o
j'appuie sur une touche et par la chute
avant un bout de terre perdu ta tête mon
bonhomme
oh [ __ ] oh là là un hammam un pardon
je voulais juste au staff lombard au
sommet mais vous voyez mais c'est
vraiment des mecs à coder ce juste
basculer ouais enfin oui regardez way
pomper pomper pomper genova tonight is
known and unknown live in a way that
salle une voiture américaine nike qui
font houba houba ébats l'appareil houba
houba
non non on bat maintenant waouh
attention ou merde
voyez c'est ça qui est marrant c'est que
quand on tombe bien vous pas tout de
suite
là par contre je crois que suis bloqué
donc falloir que ouais ouais y'a pas
moyen âge fut hachée crue ou peut être
mon blog et on la rocqué on y va on y va
on y va on y va on va temaru il ya
jacques foix allez on y va on y va on y
va on y va on y va on y va on est chauds
à voir ralentir ou alors à regarder je
sais ce qu'on va faire a fait un salto
regarder ou pas trop non plus ok et
maintenant qu'est ce qu'on fait à néant
fallait pas faire un salto
ah je vous jure du pur bonheur à jacques
royer commence à willis meucon j'ai
découvert ça par hasard sur youtube mais
je regrette mais pas mais je vous jure
qu'on voulait décompresser d'une journée
de merde un truc qu'on vous allez là
dessus au maire dont je me suis encore
un terme à changer de niveau et c'est
vraiment mais mais epic quoi ils vendent
même des t-shirts et tout j'ai vu c'est
franchement c'est vraiment marrant
andy calmer cas codesa il devait être
sacrément fou alors bmx parc à sa
maintenance ah ouais on va là voyez ça
c'est le perso je loue que je vous
disais oh allez allez ouais ouais ouais
ouais ok bon on y va on y va on y va au
quai commandes salto arrière ou au lait
aux non regardez le bébé à l'arrière
enfin le petit enfant vous allez voir
qu'il va il va décoller si je me voir
trop il habita longtemps volé ouais
ouais on échoue on est chauds obtint le
bouille hu au [ __ ] mais sérieusement
mais c'est n'importe quoi je vous jure
que sais je
c'est du pur délire mais vraiment 100%
délires en tout cas je pense ça fait un
peu de bien de changer un peu de tous
les jeux comme moi je pense pas qu'ils
aient beaucoup de français qui est fait
des vidéos lot
dubaï reste plus grand chose là je
voudrais qu'ils aient beaucoup de
youtube heures qu'ils fassent des vidéos
là dessus mais moi je vous conseille de
tester parce que franchement c'est
vraiment marrant il y avait un moyen de
bien rigoler rattaper devant brad est
donc facile et moi y avait trois top-5
et vraiment moyen de rigoler à mort mais
dommage il n'y a pas un mot de quoi vous
savez ça sera encore plus fun je pense à
deux comme ça enfin bon on va pas se
plaindre le jeu déjà bien fun ouais
ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais
ouais ouais
oh là là là là où là c'est quoi ça aux
éditions çà fait une illusion d'optique
le truc et c'est complètement perturbé
ok ok ok comme on va rater comme on va
atterrir
comment on va atterrir à bonn va par
atterrir un [ __ ] mais sérieusement
j'adore en tout cas elle est on va faire
un petit menu et après je vais stopper
la vidéo mais sérieusement c'est fou
c'est fou c'est fou c'est incroyable
alors on va faire quoi
speed bridge le pont rapide à cette
maman ça alors attendez puisque à chaque
fois je baisse la tête sans faire exprès
mais ce qui est clair c'est que j'ai dû
zoomer sur la page et tout pour filmer
vous présenter le truc derrière à la
voix rauque et un boost bridge avec
comme son nom l'indiqué c'est sur un
pont un peu cassée on va essayer de
faire des figures les gens attention
hausse au mieux je sais pas comment j'ai
fait mais je les fais mais c'est nul n'y
a rien à faire
ok ok ok oh non elle devait s'envoler
mais c'est n'importe quoi
regardez à mon dieu oh mon dieu alors
faire de cette horreur fait tourner elle
avait le parfum pas pareil on perd même
un petit bras de parpaings aux [ __ ]
mais j'ai jamais autant arriver dans une
vidéo les gens je vous assure
en tout cas je tenais à vous dire je
suis content de voir que sur ma petite
sur ma délicieuses petites chaînes ces
mondiaux dont j'ai fait un petit vidéo
et à l'aide pour vous indiquer que je
pouvais peut répondre aux messages
privés youtube mais s'est résolu et donc
je vais donc vous répondra juste après
cette vidéo enfin grande partie mais
j'ai peut-être pas faire les 200
messages mais sachez que je suis
vraiment très content que vous prenez
bien le one en ont un à dieu qui vous
vous prenez pour qui vous prenez bien le
fait que j'en ai un petit peu marre du
colloque fait que j'ai envie de de
changer un peu parce que bon voilà je
pense que le colloque le colosse le call
of vient en a marre on a un petit peu
marre on sature on s'est pris une dose
en pleine gueule en très peu de temps
une dose immense de vidéos et moi même
je faisais beaucoup de 2 sur colloque
dont j'ai décidé un peu de changer donc
comme je disais un pour ceux qui ne le
savent pas à venir du vol plané hélas
les pics voilà à venir donc dû du
kingdoms of amalur aussi dû donc un
petit mmo keller a plutôt sympathique un
peu bon c'est un peu comme si quand même
une femme quoi ainsi que du sel 0,3
ainsi que du the darkness ii donc je
sais que martèle qu'il va faire beau le
trou dessus donc soit je vais faire une
ou deux vidéos dessus avec des missions
de joueurs sélectionnés que j'adore soit
je vais peut-être faire une ou deux
vidéos avec lui en co-op je sais pas on
verra
en tout cas les gens cette vidéo match
on va y arriver on va y arriver regardez
comment on va vite
[Musique]
oui oui où
et ben voilà en tout cas j'espère que
cette petite vidéo vous aura plu le lien
du jeu et dans la description se
retrouve très bientôt pour une nouvelle
vidéo
tu as tout le monde bail et à bientôt